[Aplausos]
[Música]
amigos amigas os hago una pregunta
cuando penséis en japón que es lo
primero que nos viene a la cabeza
seguramente penséis en un país moderno
avanzado con una rica cultura
[Música]
y muchos pensaréis también en el manga
los cómics los videojuegos o incluso los
samurais vamos que seguramente tendréis
una imagen muy positiva
[Música]
sin embargo todos los países tienen sus
luces y sus sombras y hoy aquí en visual
político vamos a hablaros de un tema del
que muy poquitos medios hablan el
revisionismo histórico de japón
[Música]
revisionismo es la negación total o
parcial de acontecimientos históricos
normalmente negativos llevados a cabo
por un país en el pasado
ya tenéis biblia
[Música]
muchos países con basados difíciles de
digerir se esfuerzan por ocultar la
verdad o tratar de cambiar la versión
oficial de los hechos
y japón- amigos es uno de ellos
y es que claro démosle una vuelta si
pensamos en japón y su pasado qué es lo
que se nos ocurre probablemente samurais
quizás el doble ataque nuclear de eeuu o
como mucho el ataque de pearl harbor
aunque sólo sea por la película sin
embargo a la mayoría no se le ocurren
cosas mucho más allá de estos
acontecimientos
pero amigos sabéis lo que fue realmente
el imperio de japón
el precursor del japón moderno pero
sabéis exactamente lo que significa eso
para el extremo oriente sabías que
todavía hay heridas muy abiertas en
países que fueron víctimas de japón como
china o corea pues atentos
e
[Música]
un imperio de japón imperio del terror
efectivamente habéis escuchado bien
durante la primera mitad del siglo 20 y
especialmente durante los años 30 y 40
japón fue una potencia imperialista y
expansionista que se dedicó a invadir
países vecinos sin piedad y cuando
decimos sin piedad es algo literal sin
ningún tipo de humanidad
[Música]
durante estos años las tropas japonesas
cometieron algunos de los más atroces
atropellos a la integridad humana a la
vida y a la identidad de las personas
básicamente podríamos decir que casi
cualquiera de las peores cosas que os
podéis imaginar que puede hacer un país
las hizo japón en sus colonias
[Música]
hablamos de cosas como la esclavitud de
trabajadores para la industria y la
minería japonesa la esclavitud de
mujeres o incluso cosas más terribles
como los experimentos del escuadrón 731
que experimentaron con armas químicas en
personas cosas que puedes creernos es
mejor no reproducir de forma literal tan
solo en la ciudad china de nankín los
japoneses acabaron en dos meses con la
vida de 300.000 personas y abusaron de
más de 80.000 mujeres
[Música]
y es que amigos en los países invadidos
el imperio japonés impuso por la fuerza
su autoridad su cultura su idioma e
incluso el propio sistema político y
legal de japón hasta las obligó a la
gente a cambiarse de nombre
como podéis ver hablamos de una etapa
oscura de miedo atrocidades y violencia
sin ningún tipo de control ni límite los
soldados en los mandos intermedios
tenían carta blanca como resultado de
todo esto al menos 20 millones de
personas en asia perdieron la vida a
manos de japón 20 millones de personas
de hecho durante la guerra los datos
sobre la falta de escrúpulos del
ejército japonés ponen los pelos de
punta cerca del 40% de los prisioneros
de guerra estadounidenses que caían en
manos de los japoneses no consiguieron
sobrevivir para que os hagáis una idea
en europa esa cifra fue de menos del 2%
y no penséis que esto fue ni mucho menos
algo casual algo fortuito no la
explicación está en la cultura japonesa
milenaria conocida como bushido una
cultura que desprecia a los soldados que
se rinden en combate esto amigos es lo
que explica también que los soldados
japoneses fueran famosos por luchar
hasta las últimas consecuencias
pero bueno dejemos el pasado y vayamos
al presente veamos por qué japón se
sigue llevando tan mal con algunas de
sus ex colonias por ejemplo corea
el problema amigos es que digamos que
japón no está dejando a sus excolonias
pasar página' por culpa precisamente del
revisionismo histórico desde el ascenso
al poder del primer ministro shinzo abe
en 2012 japón ha sorprendido al mundo
con una política de revisión y negación
de su propia historia muy pero que muy
preocupante pero en qué consiste todo
esto que está haciendo shinzo abe para
cambiar o edulcorar su historia son los
japoneses de hoy realmente conocedores
de su pasado bien veámoslo
[Música]
5 al revisionismo en las instituciones
siento a veces ya una cara muy conocida
lleva desde 2012 dirigiendo japón y es
conocido sobre todo por su programa de
políticas económicas más conocido como
ave no mix de lo que ya os hemos hablado
aquí emisor político back-end young and
clean first eastern no busquen keys y
mike grandfather standing player
y ahora bien hay un aspecto de shinzo
abe mucho más controvertido del que no
se habla demasiado en occidente ave es
un revisionista abiertamente convencido
[Música]
y lo ha sido siempre desde que entró por
primera vez en la dieta el parlamento de
japón en 1993 había promovido leyes y
reformas que tratan de edulcorar la
forma en la que la historia del imperio
de japón se muestra a la sociedad por
ejemplo en su primer y breve mandato
como primer ministro entre septiembre
del año 2006 y septiembre del año 2007
había aprobó una reforma de la ley
fundamental de educación para instaurar
en el sistema educativo japonés una
visión más patriótica y con valores
morales tradicionalistas vamos puro
nacionalismo en la educación
[Música]
y por si todo esto fuera poco el propio
shinzo abe el mismísimo shinzo abe es
miembro de nippon koei y un grupo
ultranacionalista japonés fundado en
1997 que defiende abiertamente el
revisionismo histórico para exculpar de
sus crímenes al imperio de japón vamos
algo así como si en alemania merkel
formase parte de un grupo cercano a la
extrema derecha radical pero ahora bien
pensáis que ave oculta acá sobre estas
intenciones para nada los libros de
texto de eeuu desvían la historia shinzo
abe primer ministro de japón
[Música]
en efecto amigos el primer ministro a
ver no sólo modificó la ley de educación
japonesa para cambiar contenidos de la
educación sino que también critica
abiertamente cómo se aborda la historia
de japón en otros países amos que no se
esconde el revisionismo de ave se anota
goles tanto en casa como fuera
incluso el primer ministro japonés llegó
a arremeter contra la editorial mcgraw
hill por la descripción que hacía de las
mujeres forzadas por japón' a
prostituirse en la línea de batalla
mujeres que para él y los revisionistas
no eran más que voluntarias que cobraban
mucho dinero aunque todas las evidencias
históricas relatan que eran esclavas
acabó de ver el documento del libro de
texto de mcgraw-hill y me he quedado
impactado este tipo de libros de texto
están siendo usados en eeuu porque no
hemos protestado por las cosas por las
que deberíamos haber protestado y hemos
fallado en corregir las cosas que
deberíamos haber corregido shinzo abe
primer ministro de japón en os creeis
que esto fue un caso aislado el japon de
ave lleva desde que llegó al poder
implantando en las instituciones el
revisionismo más extremo impulsado por
el coro cultural nacionalista y ponga
allí
[Música]
sin ir más lejos en su discurso durante
el 70 aniversario de la rendición de
japón ab citando la muerte de los tres
millones de caídos por el imperio de
japón en el tercio sus sacrificios y los
tildó de valiosos en ese mismo acto por
cierto también habló el entonces
emperador akihito que claro es hijo de
hirohito el emperador que atacó por
hardware y desencadenó tantas guerras a
lo largo y ancho de asia pues bien en
contraste con ciento ave él se mostró
algo mas abochornado por la deriva
revisionista de su país nuestro país hoy
disfruta de paz y prosperidad gracias a
los incansables esfuerzos hechos por el
pueblo de japón hacia la recuperación de
la devastación de la guerra y hacia el
desarrollo siempre apoyado por su
fervoroso deseo de continuación de la
paz emperador akihito
[Música]
resulta curioso que el propio emperador
tenga un discurso mucho más conciliador
y humilde que el primer ministro
respecto al pasado del imperio no creéis
[Música]
y eso no es todo tanto shinzo abe como
muchos ministros diputados y senadores
de su partido visitan o envían ofrendas
con regularidad al santuario yasukuni
yasukuni es un santuario sintoísta donde
se honran entre otros a 14 criminales de
guerra de clase y del imperio de japón
criminales de guerra que fueron
declarados como tal en los juicios de
tokio el equivalente japonés a los
juicios de nuremberg para los nazis ahí
es nada pero amigo si pensáis que todo
esto es una cuestión de discursos
palabras y visitas a lugares
controvertidos estáis muy pero que muy
equivocados atentos
[Música]
el sueño por controlar la educación
así es amigos no es ningún secreto todo
lo gobernante con las aspiraciones de
cambiar la historia necesita influir en
la educación
ya os hemos contado que ave modificó la
ley educativa con este fin pero no os
creáis que se conformó sólo con esto uno
de los mayores escándalos de su gobierno
fue el de la guardería de osaka morí
tomo gakuen veréis esta guardería
privada de ideología ultranacionalista
si una guardería adoctrinaba a los niños
con una educación al más puro estilo del
imperio de japón e incluso atentos se
les hacía memorizar diariamente el
rescripto imperial sobre la educación de
1890 una especie de manifiesto con
principios del imperio a niños de 5 y 6
años pero a un momento a ver alberto que
tiene que ver sin saber con todo esto
[Música]
pues además de decir públicamente que
compartía visión ideológica con su
director yasunori ko y que había su
mujer quien por cierto fue nombrada
directora honoraria de esta guardería se
vieron inmersos en un escándalo de
favoritismo político en la venta de
terrenos públicos para la propia
guardería el escándalo de corrupción
estuvo a punto de tirar abajo al
gobierno de ave aunque al final
consiguió mantenerse en pie y ser
reelegido como primer ministro de ese
mismo año y como presidente de su
partido político en el año siguiente
pero al margen del escándalo de la
guardería imperialista en japón existe
una especie de laguna histórica en el
seno del propio sistema educativo la
profesora de historia de máquina loca
famosa por haber conseguido que 250 ex
soldados de la época del imperio de
japón admitiesen un montón de crímenes
es experta en cómo se afronta el pasado
criminal de japón en la escuela moderna
y amigos sus conclusiones son muy
desalentadoras matsuoka acusa al
gobierno de ave de silenciar
deliberadamente los acontecimientos
históricos más negativos del imperio de
japón
[Música]
por ejemplo en los libros de texto que
los estudiantes usan en las escuelas se
le dedica un simple pie de página a la
masacre de nankín de la que os hablamos
al principio de este vídeo y que queréis
que os diga 300.000 víctimas parecen
suficientes para que sea un hecho
relevante en los libros de historia no
os parece pero llegados a este punto
podemos plantearnos una pregunta
esencial qué efectos puede tener este
silencio histórico
[Música]
sí aunque empieza el político lo que más
nos guste es hablar del presente de los
cambios que se están produciendo hoy en
todo el mundo
vamos que algunos podría pensar que no
somos muy fans de mirar hacia atrás
ignorar una parte importante de la
historia tan trascendental puede llegar
a ser peligroso a la hora de tomar
decisiones políticas especialmente en
una región del mundo con tantos
sentimientos nacionales y si además los
productos culturales están también
empañados por visiones históricas
revisionistas promovidas por el propio
gobierno entonces la cosa se complica
todavía más
películas y series como por ejemplo y
eternal sido donde se ensalza la figura
de los pilotos kamikaze
son pruebas de como las versiones
nacionalistas y digamos tergiversadas de
la historia están empapando hoy a la
sociedad japonesa un fenómeno que junto
a las tensiones políticas y comerciales
de la zona parecen estar alimentando el
sentimiento nacionalista entre los
jóvenes japoneses e incrementando su
recelo hacia sus países vecinos por
ejemplo y los estudios sociológicos
dicen que el 80 por ciento el 80 por
ciento de los japoneses tienen una mala
imagen de china cifra que asciende a
casi el 60 por ciento en el caso de
corea del sur amigos amigas de visual
política tras conocer todos estos
detalles qué pensáis sobre el modelo en
que japón está afrontando su pasado
entendéis porque los asuntos históricos
son en realidad un tema de actualidad
heridas sin cerrar debería japonés
aprender de alemania para afrontar su
historia como siempre podéis dejar
vuestra opinión aquí en los comentarios
y si os ha resultado interesante este
vídeo hacérnoslo saber dándole al botón
de like un saludo y hasta la próxima
that in young mein schiff teasers no
busques sisi maytland father
shane battier
'la prensa'